tak Jak Władysław kośniak kamerzysta powiedział
że będziemy mieli
EE Po wyborach 15. października
nowy demokratyczny rząd
którego częścią będzie 3. droga
tak i spodziewam się tutaj spełnienia
obietnicy złożonej yy przez władysława koziniaka k
mysza yy na mównicy sejmowej
Szymon Hołownia sprawdził się świetnie
jako yy marszałek sejmu
potrafi ym dbać
o standardy demokratycznego państwa prawa
występuje jako marszałek wszystkich polaków
a nie jakiejkolwiek partii politycznej
potrafi łączyć
a nie dzielić
budować te ym
mosty porozumienia
które są polakom potrzebne
i znakomicie sprawdzi się jako
prezydent rzeczypospolitej polskiej